ما مدى دقه كلام اردوغان تذكر ان العمليه
تاخرت لاشهر بسبب المعارضه الروسيه
الامريكيه لها وبالتالي تركيا طولي
الاهتمام بالفعل لموافقه الطرفين وان كانت
عمليه اسطنبول الاخيره مثلا دفعتا للتحرك
التركي جوا والاشتياح البري له حسابات
مختلفه تتعلق بنجاعه الهجوم كوارث
الى نبع السلام الاسم الذي اطلقته تركيا
على عمليتها العسكريه الثالثه في شرق
الفرات في 2019 وبعد فرضها واقعا على
الارض التفاهمات مع موسكو واشنطن اوقفت
العمليه اليوم تعلن انقره المخلب السيف في
اتجاه وتعول في اخر على الوساطه الروسيه
لتلبيه المقاتلين الاكراد لما طالبها دون
قتال وبنسحابهم منبج عين العرب قتل رفعت
بل وتسليم مقار قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه
لقوات النظام
وهنا واقع اخر جديد تحاول تركيا ترسيخه
منذ مده تتفق فيه مع روسيا ان لم تكن
موسكو هي من تدفع باتجاهه وبقوه وسنعود
اليه بكل الاحوال في الوساطه الجمعه قائد
القوات الروسيه في سوريا
بقائد قصد مظلوم عبدي في مدينه القامشلي
لترحيل الرساله التركيه الاخيره قبل بدء
العمليات البريه
في شمال وشرق سوريا كذلك الذي فرضته في
2018 في الجنوب سلسله اتفاقيات تكون فيها
الضامن فيما سيستفيد النظام السوري
بالدخول الى مناطق اوسع تماما كما ساعد في
نوفمبر العام الماضي الى ادخال ثلاثه الاف
مقاتل من قوات النظام الى عين العرب لكن
هل هي مصلحه خالصه لنظام
الاجابه في الشروط والمحددات التي تحكم
الساحه السوريه